je m'appelle franklyn
j'ai pas toujours vécu ici ma vie était
totalement différente y encore peu de
temps
c'était l'époque où je vivais avec mon
frère bernard et depuis je vis seul
peut-être que je devrais déménager
qu'est ce que vous en pensez et monsieur
olivetti je vais tuer il est couché là
sur le plancher à tous qu'il fasse nuit
et nous pizza ans celui-ci à ce que ça
conserve
en suisse ils disent que les preuves
matérielles laisse à penser dans cet
abonné repris y était et est mort dans
un incendie hier soir il va bien non il
est mort il faisait ses bagages il
disait déménagé en suède quelque chose
du genre
la suède la suisse partout il croit
qu'une défense d'éléphant géant
ressemble à un instrument de musique
en utilisant ma méthode éprouvée vous
allez considérablement réduire vent
risquent de succomber à une attaque
cérébrale en plein milieu d'une cure
d'abstinence de 45 jours quand je me
débarrasse tout s'est tu aurais pas
fatale a préféré encore d'enfoncer cette
fourchette dans la gorge c'est toi qui
vois
nous n'avons qu'une seule lui n'est pas
de deuxième chance le temps gaspillé et
du temps perdu aucune importance que
l'on vive dans un petit appartement ou
dans une grande villa sous la colline
tout est dans la tête
parce que le bonheur est un état
d'esprit tu as l'air d'un gentil chien
kan veut m'oblige pas à boire tout seul
tu veux